يتعامل النظام في ايران مع الاحتجاجات
التي دشنت شهرها الرابعه على انها تهديد
الوجود
لذلك يلجا الى نواه صلبه موال يا رغم
اقليتها للحفاظ على الاسس التي قام عليها
عام
وفق تحقيق لصحيفه
هذا النظام تعتمد على الاف المواليد
المخلصين كحصن اساسي ضد الاحتجاجات
ابرزهم الحرس الثوري والباسيج وميليشيات
المحليه اخرى هؤلاء الموالون السلطات
الايرانيه لاخماد انتفاضه المحتجين في
الشوارع اضافه الى الدفاع عن قيام الثوره
الاسلاميه التي اسسها الخميني لكن الولاء
لا تضمنه العقائد فقط بل الامتيازات اشارت
صحيفه جورنال الى ان هذه النواه الموالي
الصلبه غالبا ما يكون اعضائها من خلفيات
متواضعه اقتصاديا ومحافظه اجتماعيا
وبضمان ولائها او تعزيزه يمنح النظام في
ايران امتيازات ووظائف واسلحه ويعطي
اولادهم افضليه التعليم في ابرز الجامعات
الايرانيه لكن كل ذلك غير كافي فقد حمل
استطلاع اجرته مؤسسه بحثيه غير الربحيه
تتخذ منه هولندا مقرا لها انباء سيئه
للسلطات الايرانيه وان كانت متوقعه لدى
اجهزه الاستخبارات اشار الاستطلاع الى ان
واحدا من اصل خمسه ايرانيين يدعمون النظام
الحالي
مؤشر يبرر قلق السلطات الايرانيه
ويعزز ثقه المحتجين